- Okay.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
Thank you, and welcome.
We're gonna go ahead and start today
with a few interesting facts.
The first being, did you know
that for every breakthrough
drug that makes it to market,
pharmaceutical companies analyze
over 10 million patient data points?
And yet 80% of healthcare
data remains unstructured
and difficult to access.
In today's rapidly evolving
healthcare landscape
real-world data and real-world evidence
are a game changer in how we
understand patient outcomes
and develop new treatments.
In fact, studies show that
leveraging real-world evidence
in clinical trials can
reduce clinical trial times
by up to 40% and cut
the costs by millions.
I'm Anne Evans,
and I serve as the Strategic
Solution Development Program
Leader in AWS Industries'
Healthcare and Life Sciences.
Today I'm joined by Greg
Cunningham from Eli Lilly,
who will share how Lilly is
revolutionizing their approach
to real-world data.
And Eric Brooks, our AWS
Principal Solution Architect,
who will dive into agentic workflows
and how we are transforming
data accessibility.
So whether you're a
pharmaceutical researcher,
a healthcare provider,
or a data scientist,
we're genuinely excited
to share how we've been
collaborating with our partners
and customers to accelerate
and simplify access
to real-world data.
So let's dive into how
data is used in healthcare
and life sciences and how AWS
is revolutionizing data access.
In the last decade,
global data generation,
all data being generated,
has increased 11 fold
from 16 zetabytes in 2015
to 181 zetabytes of data
floating around at the end of 2025.
The same is true in healthcare data.
Between the imaging data, the lab data,
all the data that is becoming
available in healthcare,
we are projecting a 10
zetabytes of healthcare data
being available at the end of 2025.
This proliferation of data availability
has driven transformative growth,
evolving the use of real-world data
and real-world evidence
from an emerging field
to a mainstream component in
pharmaceutical development
and healthcare decision making.
But while this exponential growth
creates unprecedented opportunities,
it also creates critical challenges
such as how do you organize,
access and make value
from such massive volumes of information?
So before we dive into
more specifics about this,
with a quick show of hands,
how many of you are familiar
with real-world data and how it is used
in healthcare and life sciences?
Excellent. Thank you.
So for those newer to this space,
real-world data is healthcare data
collected during routine patient care,
which means it's everything
from electronic health records
to wearable devices to the
insurance claims we all make.
Real-world evidence is what we learn
from analyzing this data.
This evidence is used to provide insights
into the possible benefits
and risks of medical products.
It's also used to study clinical
conditions and biomarkers
when developing new drugs.
Driven by an increase in demand
for data-backed decision making,
for accelerated drug development,
for value-based care models,
and of course the continual
regulatory expectations
across pharmaceutical,
biotech and med devices,
this increasing demand
for evidence and insight
is driving a surge in the demand
for real-world data-backed studies.
The evidence that is being generated
is used to help boost preventative efforts
to identify patients that
are at risk of illness
or eligible for clinical trials.
It's used to shape clinical trials.
It's also used to create public policy
and expand drug safety testing.
It's used to determine the value
of medical-based intervention
and to establish reimbursement
strategies while supporting
regulatory expectations.
We create this flywheel
because the more data
that is available, the more
evidence is being used,
creating that demand for yet more data.
This is why establishing a strong data
foundation layer is essential.
To effectively use the
data and allow agents
to use the data to generate
these insights and evidence,
we must start with a strong
data foundation layer.
In life sciences, this
includes historical data
that is sitting in your warehouses
or on individual scientists' workstations.
It's experimental data being
generated in your labs,
computational data being
run in simulations.
And then when you take all of your data
and you mix it with third-party data
that will enrich your data,
increasing the breadth and
the depth of the questions
that you can answer with
information previously unavailable,
the ability to make that data
work for you is limitless.
But we have to remember it all starts
with the data foundation layer
because the most
sophisticated AI in the world
will only ever be as smart and effective
as the data that it can access.
Despite this tremendous growth
that we've talked about,
finding the right data,
the data that you need,
continues to be messy and challenging.
It's unpredictable, which
in this case is fitting
for data that comes from the real world.
Today, 40% of data
purchases are incomplete,
which really means ineffective.
And given that real-world
data is collected all along
that patient care journey,
there's no one source,
no one provider that
will have all of the data
that you need.
And yet, 70% of studies
require very specific,
fit for purpose data that is linked
across multiple datasets.
And with HIPAA requirements
that all of our data
remains de-identified,
connecting patient data
across multiple datasets
is extremely challenging.
When you're looking for very
specific fit for purpose data,
this fragmentation creates major hurdles.
For example, it typically
takes four to 12 weeks
just to find and obtain what
looks to be the necessary
third-party data.
This is further complicated
by data producers'
reluctance to share data
outside of their control.
And once you've obtained the data
because each producer will
use their own unique format,
you still have to harmonize that data,
which is gonna add another
four weeks to your process.
And then once you've done all of that
and you have your data,
your different team members
from the computational scientist
to the experimental scientist,
they all need their own tools
to make that data
effectively work for them.
All of these challenges create
timelines exceeding 10 years
and cost in the millions.
Depending on the therapeutic area,
even in the two to $3 billion range
just to put that new drug out to market.
At AWS, we're approaching
this complex challenge
with a comprehensive multi-part solution.
In the first part, shown here,
we are streamlining data
discovery and access.
We've been collaborating
with our AWS partner Datavant
to build a solution on AWS Clean Rooms
that uses Datavant's privacy
preserving technology
to help researchers quickly find, analyze,
and obtain linked patient
level data sources.
In this solution data
producers host their tokenized,
personally identifiable
information in their AWS account.
Data consumers can then
discover and evaluate
multimodal fit for purpose
data across Datavant's
broad network of data producers.
Consumers will then negotiate
directly with the producer,
subscribe to the data
in a private offering
with billing directly
through AWS Data Exchange.
Datavant's proprietary
software takes an individual's
personally identifiable
information such as name,
gender, and date of birth,
and converts it into a
unique string of characters
known as a token that
de-identifies the information.
Now this is a token that is
different than an LLM token.
This token is specific to Datavant,
that is within their proprietary software.
Each token in each dataset
is unique to an individual patient.
And yet, with Datavant's
proprietary software,
consumers are able to
connect patient level data
with this token all without revealing
any underlying personally
identifiable information.
Because that same patient
will always generate
that same encrypted,
nonreversible deterministic token,
that same patient unique token can be used
to link datasets with that
token across all of these
multiple datasets at the patient level,
which will provide that
longitudinal patient journey.
And this tokenization happens
in the data producer's
container behind that
data producer's firewall,
ensuring that no personal
identifiable information
is actually leaving the data
producer's secure system.
Through our collaboration with Datavant,
we have been working with
healthcare organizations
and life sciences companies
to bring this tokenized data
into AWS Clean Rooms,
transforming how we access
and analyze these valuable datasets.
Datavant Connect, powered
by AWS Clean Rooms,
gives data producers the ability
to discover and evaluate fit
for purpose multimodal data
in a HIPAA compliant
privacy preserving manner.
For data producers, this new
discovery and evaluation method
allows them to share their
data with data consumers
while maintaining complete control.
Because no data has actually moved
in between these environments,
data consumers retain the ability
to share as much or as little of the data
as that data producer deems necessary.
For data consumers,
multiple personas are able
to discover and evaluate
fit for purpose data
with an easy to use front end agent
that acts as their own virtual assistant,
helping to ensure that
they find the right data.
So how does this all work?
Data sources host their tokenized,
personally identifiable
information in the AWS account.
They register directly with
the Datavant Connect platform.
They do this by creating a Glue database
and a Glue table that has pointers
to their S3 bucket and table schema.
Consumers then evaluating
different datasets
will use AWS Clean Rooms as a secure,
neutral evaluation space.
Again, meaning that no data
is moving between these environments.
While researchers are able to evaluate
multiple datasets simultaneously,
drastically reducing evaluation time,
data producers don't
have to manually update
their information in the
Datavant Connect platform
because that live connection
with AWS Clean Rooms
ensures that their latest
data is always available.
Then once the right data is found,
Datavant will certify the
data and it can be seamlessly
procured through AWS Data Exchange.
Pilot customers have been
testing this solution
and they've been sharing how
they are unlocking access
to data that once available
is accelerating timelines
like never before.
For the second part of this
solution, shown here in blue,
we have been working with
partners such as Aetion
and their Activate platform,
Manifold and their data layer,
and Panalgo with the IHD Cloud,
to enable faster insights
through modern, scalable
data harmonization platforms,
which allows us to support both technical
and non-technical users.
Technical users like
biostatisticians and data scientists
will use open source
tools like R and Python,
but non-technical users can access
these agentic capabilities
to build cohorts
applying that inclusion exclusion criteria
when analyzing that
longitudinal patient journey.
Through our collaboration with Eli Lilly,
we have developed this agent
that allows non-technical users
to analyze complex healthcare datasets
using natural language.
Built on AWS's AI stack,
our agent seamlessly
connects to data sources
across Redshift, S3,
Athena and Databricks.
Now with data delivered
directly to the S3 bucket,
with automated harmonization,
technical users continue
using R and Python
and non-technical users
can access the agent
to act as a persona-driven
virtual assistant
making sense of the data
and providing insights instantaneously,
all within a responsible,
auditable framework.
This streamlined approach eliminates
the traditional bottlenecks
while maintaining data security
and data privacy.
And what used to take four months
now can be done in under four weeks.
As we continue to navigate
the evolving field
of real-world data and evidence,
AWS continues to actively
collaborate with multiple partners
and customers to tackle
the complex challenges
of real-world data discovery and analysis.
Companies such as Manifold,
Deloitte, Panalgo, Aetion,
EPAM and Atropos are all
leveraging AWS infrastructure
and incorporating AI agents
to transform real-world data analysis.
It's important to remember these solutions
are not just about data processing.
These solutions are about intelligent,
automated decision making
that is identifying patterns,
generating evidence and
insights that is accelerating
that path from data through
evidence to discovery.
But as we stated earlier,
it all starts with the
data foundation layer.
Because even the most
sophisticated AI in the world
will only ever be as smart and effective
as the data that it can access.
So with that,
I am really excited to welcome
our next speaker to the stage,
who will share firsthand experience
of putting this technology to work.
It is my pleasure to
introduce Greg Cunningham,
Senior Director of Real-World
Data from Eli Lilly.
Greg brings an impressive 12 years
of real-world data across
Lilly's pharmaceutical portfolio.
Greg's insights will be invaluable
as he shares their real-life experience
and concrete examples of
using this technology.
So please join me in giving
a warm welcome to Greg.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Anne.
It's great to be here.
This is the first time
I've been at re:Invent.
Like Anne said, I work
at Eli Lilly & Company.
We're a pharmaceutical company
based in Indianapolis, Indiana.
Unlike my four sons, I've been
at one company for 39 years.
I've been the last 12
in real-world evidence
responsible for our licensing and data
and also the data platforms
that we have the data on.
Prior to that, I worked in
our clinical trial area,
working on new drugs that
made it to the market.
And today I want to talk, like Anne said,
about kind of a couple of things,
the business need for
a scientific company,
but I think this goes beyond
just a scientific company.
I think any company can follow the pattern
that we have done with AWS,
so we'll dive into that.
In pharma companies, the
gold standard for data,
that data foundation,
is clinical trial data.
This data is very clean, it
follows very rigid standards.
It's really looked after to
make sure it's high quality.
And when I first started with Lilly,
we would do a lot of phase four studies
after we got approved.
These studies helped us understand
what was going on with the patient
after the drug was approved
'cause there was really
no other way to know
what was going on at that time.
But then healthcare
changed with the, you know,
the healthcare records going
from paper to electronic.
If you go to a doctor's office today,
they aren't writing a lot down on paper,
they're doing most of it in tablet
or computer to enter directly.
So we found a new source
of healthcare research data
that allowed us to stop doing costly
and slow clinical trials,
to do more real-time work
of ingesting data like this
that I'll talk about in a minute.
But, first, what is real-world evidence?
I have a definition that the FDA uses
and, you know, it's clinical evidence
about the use and the potential benefits
and risk of a product derived solely
from these electronic
healthcare sources in the system
that we all use in our
U.S. healthcare system
and in other countries too now.
And at Lilly, we kind of have
formulated our own formula.
To get this evidence you see to the right,
there's three key ingredients.
First, you have to have
a scientific question
or a hypothesis you want to test.
The foundational thing I
think Anne covered really well
is the data.
Getting the right data, our
group spends time helping people
get the data that has the best
quality for their question,
but also looking at
what variables they need
and ensuring those variables are present
in the datasets they use.
And then, finally, having
a statistical analysis plan
and then the execution of the analytics.
This RWE is increasingly more vital
and important to life science companies
because we wanna have
actionable real-time insights
to what's happening to our drug
now that its left the clinical trial area
and it's being used out in the real world,
and the results are not always the same
and there's sometimes surprises
on what patients you're
getting in the market.
Real-world evidence is used
across the whole product
lifecycle that we have.
You know, when I look at the uses,
we use it in our early phase discovery
as we're trying to discover new molecules,
to we use it in our clinical trials
and we use it post-launch,
like I mentioned earlier.
The clinical trial examples I can give,
we have protocols that we
are always trying to improve
to make them easier for the
physician to do the trial.
And in doing that we
use real-world evidence
to identify what's the best, you know,
inclusion and exclusion
criterias we can have?
It's best to use real data
to then make those decisions
at what cut points you get
patients with the disease.
And the health outcomes
function that I am part of,
we do observational studies.
So these studies,
we're looking to demonstrate
what's the economic value
of the product and what's the
comparative effectiveness?
We'll look at one of our
drugs versus the competitor's.
We know the clinical trial results.
We also will publish papers to show
is this drug performing the same or higher
or lower in the real world?
And our end goal with that exercise
is to publish in scientific journals.
And this is one of the
high-priority things
we do in our area.
But after you launch in the market,
we also use it to look at
patient characteristics.
Who did we think we were gonna get
in our marketing plans and who actually
is taking your drug and
how's it performing?
There are a variety of RWD types.
Anne talked about it at
kind of a macro level.
I'll give you some
perspectives of how we see data
and using it today.
The last 10 to 15 years we've
used that foundational data
you see on the screen.
It's been the tried and true
data for real-world data.
Electronic health records,
as it became electronic.
It's got great clinical variables
for people to use to understand.
Lab data is usually in there.
The the one we use the
most in health outcomes
is claims and billing data from insurance
because it gives you every
healthcare transaction
someone had over a long period of time.
'Cause a lot of us are with
the same insurer over time,
it's very nice to give you that long view.
I would say that the foundational data
is typically broad, it's all diseases
because they're big databases
and that's what they're
used for predominantly.
The most exciting thing
in the last few years
is this emerging data.
Our holy grail is to have data
that really is disease specific,
that tells you is the
disease getting worse
or is it getting better?
So wearables, sensors and health apps
are really, really critical.
An example of how pharma
companies use, you know,
an app, I've seen migraine studies
where they've had people using the app
who are migraine patients.
They enter every time they have a migraine
and they enter the severity.
Well then that gives us the ability
to see what drug they were on
and then which drug is
actually reducing the severity
and or the amount of migraines.
So this merging of broad
data and this deep,
rich data is extremely helpful.
As the human genome is
continuing to evolve
biomarkers and genomic data are critical.
Our oncology team uses a lot of this data
with our real-world data to match up
and see which biomarkers
are really making an impact
with our drugs and are modifying
the disease or treating it.
The last thing Anne
talked about the token,
so I won't kind of talk about the process,
but the token allowed
us to take this broad,
longitudinal data and match it up
with deep and rich data from the disease
and we're able to do
much, much richer analysis
that is helping us understand
the patient journey
that people are on and how do
we help impact their lives.
The acquiring of real-world
data and ingesting it
is a process that I think you're starting
to see Datavant and AWS really crack
and change where this is going.
Our process isn't much
different that you see here
from other pharma companies.
We spend time, okay, what's
the scientific question?
What's that need that someone has?
And then our team, the
real-world data team,
looks at how do you evaluate what data
is gonna best meet that need?
We have data already
purchased and licensed inside
versus the external market,
which is changing every week.
So we spend, on those first two boxes,
I've seen it take, I think,
Anne, your numbers was months.
I've actually seen it take
up to a year at times.
So we're trying to figure out
how can you do this better and faster?
Once you've made the
decision, the transfer,
ingestion and moving the data,
we use Redshift database for our analysis.
Those things we're real
excited 'cause the Datavant,
AWS solution they're
looking to put in place
will take that from, I've seen
this take a couple of months
and, you know, if this can
get down to a month or less,
it allows us to use more current data,
real-time data, faster.
And so we're real excited
with where the technology
is going in this space.
You know, I've talked
about real-world evidence.
I've talked about real-world data.
To set the context of the challenges
we're facing in generating
evidence from real-world data.
Having been in this
space more than a decade,
I've seen us try to hire analysts,
statisticians, data scientists,
and we have made huge leaps,
but we're still dependent on analytic pros
who are those data
scientists and statisticians.
These end users, our scientists,
use and count on these folks
to do those publications,
to do regulated work.
So for us, it's the core,
it's the most important work we do.
We have trouble just staffing that
with all the improvements we've done
with all the changes we've done,
that is really keeping us busy.
And we've added more and more people
and it's not solving the problem.
So we took on...
I'll talk in a minute on the next slide
about what we did to try to address this.
The second thing we've had,
it's a significant learning curve.
This data is not collected
for like a clinical trial.
This data is collected for insurance,
it's collected for your
doctor's notes, for billing.
It is not meant for this.
So it is not as clean and accurate.
And with that and then
the completeness issues,
this data is much more difficult.
And when new analysts
or new statisticians,
it takes up to six months for them
to be really productive in this space.
The third issue is real-world data
does not have clear standards.
There are several floating around.
Not one of 'em has just not
taken over and made it easy.
And this hinders the ability to make tools
or write standard code that
can be used and leveraged.
So what we did, to expand on,
we had the first two columns you see.
Our original users were
doing complex coding
using AWS Cloud platform.
We've done a lot of
great work in this space.
We then said, okay, we've
gotta do something different
because we can't get enough work.
We took some of our scientists
who actually did coding in college,
they did their own analysis.
We'd let them use an analytic
tool that's on the market.
It's a low-code environment.
They're able to enter parameters
and get output themselves,
answer questions themselves.
So to the left, we do those publications,
we do those regulated activities.
This middle is to let them
generate their own answers,
but we found that not all the scientists
have the same background,
it's not easy for them all to use a tool.
So we worked with Amazon to
say, how can we change the game?
How can we have a no-code environment
where people can enter a text question
to get results running across our data?
So we've been working
on this for over a year
and it has come to fruition,
we're going live next week.
And those scientist users are able
to get questions answered themselves.
They can even do it in a meeting
where someone on the clinical team asks,
"Hey, what's the percent of
patients that have disease X?"
Or, "What's the most
common drug in this space?"
These are questions that
we don't have time to give
to a statistician and it
may take a week or longer
for them do it, if they
can get to it at all.
So this is a way to let
self-service take over.
I would say the biggest
things we've learned
through doing this is the agent,
the LLMs and all those
things, they do great work,
but they need context,
they need business context
that's in my head, it's in our analyst,
our statisticians head.
So, you know, really putting those things
that run before the agents
so that we can put that context in
and allow the agent to write better code.
The second thing we learned in the testing
was your questions, the more general
the more assumptions you're
gonna have from your agent
because it's trying to figure
out what you're saying.
So we've told our users be very specific.
If you want data from
the prescription claims,
say that in your question.
Don't leave it to be hanging out there.
And this has produced a greater accuracy.
The last thing I would say is
as we had people do questions,
I thought you'd just put
in a big block of questions
and it would spit out
the answers and enter it,
get your answers, move on.
It's a dialogue.
You have to ask question,
then ask another question
and another question.
And the answers and the
accuracy of those answers
have gotten better because of that.
Scientists by nature are very skeptical.
So we're worried about releasing a tool
that people who are
very skeptical will say,
well, is this answer right?
And I've had that question
four times already from our scientists.
And so we're gonna do some
tests of real questions
that they ask as we go live,
to just give them a little more sense of,
yes, this is on the right path.
The code being written,
the SQL code being written,
has actually been very
good and it's improved
every step of the way so far.
So we're very, very excited to
go live with this next week.
We did a pilot group,
and with the pilot group,
our intent was to take people
who are more tech savvy,
take people who were into this
and they're gonna be the
soft launch that we go with
and then we'll go with a
hard launch with the people
maybe who are less techy and those people
who sit with them can work with them more.
So I think that's been
some of the learnings
we've seen so far.
So I will finish here,
and I'm very excited to have Eric Brooks
join us and give his firsthand experience
of implementing what we've just discussed.
Eric is a Principal Solution
Architect from Amazon,
and he has worked with us
over the last year and a
half to bring this to life.
Please give Eric a warm welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Hey everyone.
Thanks, Greg. I appreciate it.
You know, what we've seen
so far is this journey
from really data acquisition.
You know, we're buying the
data from various providers,
we're loading it into
Redshift or S3, you know,
there we're governing
access with permissions
through Redshift access
through SageMaker lakehouse.
And we've gotten to the point
now we've made data available,
but we have to tackle this complex,
multimodal, you know, disparate
dataset kind of landscape
because, you know, as Greg described,
what we're not talking about here
is a simple sales dataset.
This is not simple data
that can simply be queried
by a text to SQL agent.
And what we're also not talking about
is a simple text to SQL use case.
You know, one of the most
common questions we get is,
is how does this type of a solution
differ from a common text to SQL?
We've seen this a million times already.
You know, nothing new.
And so as we explored this use case
with Greg and his team,
what we found is that
this is very much well fit
for an agentic use case.
But as we tried to move
through this process
of taking this mountain of data,
one data provider I think provides
something like 15 terabytes on
a monthly basis of new data,
how do we go ahead and tackle
that kind of an evolving landscape
where data might be siloed
across different services,
maybe different data modalities,
perhaps even different data schemas
or oftentimes different data schemas?
You know, with a research team
and ultimately a consumer
team, which aren't SaaS coders,
they're not our coders,
they're not Python developers,
they're not deeply knowledgeable
about this use case.
They don't know that things
like continuous enrollment matter
when it comes to claims data
from a quality perspective.
And so what we're trying to tackle
is this how do we build a system
that uses the most recent
frontier models from Anthropic
and Amazon to make sure that
we can democratize the access
to this data and make
sure, as Greg mentioned,
that it's the most accurate
and the highest quality outputs
because these are critical things
that people are interested in at Lilly?
And so, you know, and
then we have to decide
how are we gonna architect that system?
And then, of course,
that's what I'm here
for to talk about today.
But I always think it's good to start
with a really solid mental model.
So as we think about agents,
there's a lot of talk
about agents in the market.
We heard a lot of updates
from Matt this morning
about AgentCore and about
all the capabilities
within AWS to build agents.
But I always like to start
with a good mental model
so that I can understand the
system I'm trying to build.
And so the thing I always
start with is, what's the goal?
You know, what's the user
experience I'm trying to provide?
Am I just trying to provide SQL queries
or am I trying to build
a system which outputs
real analysis that has rich insights,
that has, you know, solid visualizations,
that has a really, you
know, high speed experience,
sort of high quality, high
performance experience?
So what am I working backwards from?
At Amazon, we like to talk
about working backwards
and that's a very
important thing to define,
is what's the goal and
what's the goal of the agent?
And then I start to think about,
okay, well if I understand the goal,
then I know maybe what
tools I'm gonna use.
As a human, I have lots of
tools that are available to me.
I have a Python notebook
or I have a SaaS console,
or I have my email client, you know,
anything that I use that lives
within the technology realm
is a tool of some kind.
I have a tool in my hand right here.
It doesn't do that much,
but it's pretty important
to the job that I'm doing.
So what are the tools that I need?
If let's say I was a
human doing this process
or doing this job,
what are the tools I would
need to get that job done?
And probably more importantly,
what are the tools that I need to be able
to develop the knowledge in the moment
where I've been asked that question
to be able to answer that question?
That's a really important thing to know.
Then I have to start
to define the protocol.
What are the steps I have
to take to get to that thing
that I'm trying to go towards?
And the goal and the protocol
are really what's gonna help you start
to work towards what's the prompt
that I'm gonna hand to the agent,
and we'll talk about this in a few slides,
in order for it to be able to do its job?
And then, finally,
if I'm thinking about
a multi-agent system,
well then I also have
to start thinking about
what are the handoffs?
Because what I don't want
to do is say I've got six
or seven or eight agents in a system
and I'm gonna hand every
agent all the context
of all of the conversations,
of all the things that have come before
because that's not a successful
architecture approach.
So what are the handoffs?
If I have a team of people
working on a problem,
I'm not just gonna do a data dump
of all the things that have come before.
I'm gonna say, here's the things you need,
here's what I'm asking of you,
and here's maybe some guidance
on perhaps how to do the job.
Please, you know, use your
tools, come back to me.
And that's very much the mental model
for how to start to think about
and align multi-agent teams
to be able to accomplish a task.
And so there are critical decisions
we have to make along the way.
The first one is, what type of system
is gonna fit my use case
the most effectively?
Can I build it with a single agent?
Can I simply just have a text to SQL agent
which uses the myriad of tools
and the capabilities that
I need that has a prompt,
that has additional context
that's going to be able
to answer the questions,
that total set of questions
that I think I'm gonna have to answer?
Or do I want to think about
this more in the sense
of specialized skills and
capabilities and knowledge sets,
context, that's gonna be
able to break a problem down
and be able to answer it effectively?
One of the biggest learnings
for me in working with Greg
and his team early on
was that in the context
of real-world data analysis, you know,
getting to that real-world
evidence outcome
is there are lots of different personas
or skills that are
involved in this process.
It's not just a text to SQL agent
that looks at the data and says, you know,
here's your SQL statement and you move on.
That's not the problem we're
trying to solve here at all.
And I think, as Greg
mentioned, in a lot of cases,
even if you're not looking
at real-world evidence
or real-world data,
you may find that some of these similar
kinds of aspects are also
a part of your use case.
It's not just about the dataset.
There's adjacent data,
there's context that you need
to be able to answer complex questions
to really build a system that scales
and that generalizes to
a larger problem set.
And so as we look at the single agent
versus multi-agent comparison,
we have this trade-off,
it's the classic architecture trade-off.
It's complexity for capability.
And so in the multi-agent
system, as we did in this case,
what we ended up with is
this more complex system,
which was orchestrated by
an underlying framework,
which enabled us to define agents
which encapsulated the key capabilities,
those functionalities, that were necessary
to be able to scale to meet
the needs of the team at Lilly.
And so as we look at a multi-agent system,
then we start to realize
that maybe we need
a manager of sorts.
You know, if we have a larger team,
we like to talk about two
pizza teams at Amazon.
And usually that team has a manager,
and that manager is sort of the decider
of what the business wants,
say if you have a developer team.
And so that manager, in
this case, the supervisor,
is an agent that works with the user
that's kind of that front door.
So the agent is going
to be able to identify
what the user is looking for,
do some entity recognition,
some sort of, you know,
some summarization,
and then it's gonna
work with its partners.
Say a SQL expert, a medical coder,
these are some of the
aspects of this use case
that are really important.
Even a research planner,
an agent who's familiar
with a general methodology
of how to answer
questions in this context,
as well as the data navigator.
One of the things that
we found very quickly too
is because of what Greg
mentioned around the fact
that there's not a consistent standard
for most of these datasets and the fact
that we don't have the
convenience of saying,
hey, let's ETL this data
all into the same format,
into the same schema,
that we need to be able to
meet the data where it is.
And so we need to be able to
navigate multiple datasets
to understand very quickly
on where to find the
answer to the question
in a data set which has tens of tables.
And then, finally, we need to be able
to actually interact with that dataset.
So how do we interact with the landscape?
And it's not just the underlying data.
One of the biggest learnings
for me was that there are many,
many code sets, for example,
as reference data that's critical
to translating a human question,
which we'll see here
in a couple of slides,
into what we actually need to know.
So it's not necessarily in the data set
the thing that we're trying to find,
but I need to take a
couple stops along the way
to be able to get the right context.
And so as we started to think more
and more about this problem,
this is where the module three
from what Anne was talking
about earlier really came out.
And so what we landed on was
seven specialized agents.
The first, of course, is the assistant,
or that's the supervisor,
that's the thing that chats with the user.
The next one is the SQL creator.
Of course, we can't do
this without interacting
with a structured dataset so, of course,
we need to write some SQL, which is great.
Then we need a medical coder.
So if I ask a question
about say a diagnosis
or some medication or some
lab procedure or other things,
or maybe I ask about all three,
I need an expert in medical coding
to make sure that I can translate
that human question if I
don't know all those codes,
and most people don't, neither
do the LLMs by the way,
without the right context,
into the the real question.
Then we need to create visualizations,
we need to make a
research plan potentially
from our complex questions,
we may even need to
consult some publications.
And then, finally, we need
to be able to navigate
that data and do so in
a way which integrates
with that complex, harmonized dataset
there you see in module two.
And so it's always good to
zoom in on one of these agents
to really see what it's doing.
And so the neat thing
about an agent is it works
very much like my brain does,
like your brain probably does
where you say, I've got a problem,
I wanna solve it, but I
have to iterate over it.
I have to think about the problem
and understand the problem
before I can go and solve that.
And that's exactly what an agent does.
It has this iterative execution loop,
it's a cyclical node on
a graph, in this case,
that takes a number of inputs.
So it starts with the prompt
and the reasoning loop.
This notion of of iterating
over a problem until it's solved
and really until the
agent decides it's solved,
which is even more interesting.
And so it's gotta perform some
kind of structured reasoning.
This is something that's built into LLMs.
So you hear about tool-calling,
function-calling, instruction following.
These are all aspects of what makes LLMs
the reasoning engine behind this process.
Then I need to be able to
do things like in this case,
since my task is to plan
and execute SQL queries
and provide analysis, I
need to be able to plan
the query structure and
potentially have examples.
And I've got the graph state,
this is all the things
that happened before.
Have there been other
actions, other agents,
has the medical coding
agent already deciphered
all that complex human
language into a set of codes
or have there been queries run before?
Has somebody asked a question
and then asked a follow up question
as the process that that Greg described?
But there's something missing here
because this isn't enough to
be able to accomplish this.
We need a set of tools and we
need a set of curated tools
to be able to make this agent
able to do the things it's doing.
Just like as a human,
I would use say a query
reference database,
or I would use a dataset metadata.
So, for example, I might
use a data dictionary
or I might go into the database
and look at the actual table DDL.
So I'm gonna be looking
through table and column names,
foreign key relationships,
data types and constraints
as I'm constructing a query.
And that's exactly what
an agent has to do.
It has to have the context to be able
to solve the problem in front of it.
And, by the way,
this is something that
applies to any agent.
Remember back to our mental model,
this is about defining the tools
that enable the agent
to accomplish the task.
But then there's more to it.
There's few-shot prompts.
So we've got that in as
a part of the tool set.
So an interesting part about
this is this is a good way
to integrate that human in the loop.
So what we found here was that a great set
of baseline ground truth queries
that answer related questions
are a really, really good
way to encourage an LLM
to make the right decisions
when it comes to query generation.
And so taking those golden
queries as we've stated here,
and making them available
through a semantic search,
so a similarity search or
a similar meaning search
to the agent on demand through a tool
is a great way to encourage
and improve outputs.
Also having SQL validation
so we have a very quick way
to validate those queries.
And then the ability to actually execute
and manage the outputs of those
queries is really important.
And then, finally, what that
leads us to is this idea
of being able to not only
generate multiple queries,
execute them, troubleshoot them,
gather information and
context around them,
to then take that and actually
turn that into analysis.
And so that's all part
of that define the role,
define the tools, define the protocol,
and then define the handoff that results
in a set of agents which can answer
a complex set of questions
through this iterative,
cyclical execution loop
with context gathering and
then eventual analysis.
So let's talk about how
this actually works.
So we've got a question here.
What is the age distribution
of patients diagnosed
with hypertension who
are prescribed drug X
in the last 12 months?
So there are about four or
five different attributes
depending on how you
look at that question.
So how do we break that down?
Well, it starts with the
supervisor, of course,
that's the entry point to this graph.
And so the supervisor is
gonna look at that question
and say, well, I gotta
come up with a plan.
I see that there's
demographic information,
there's a diagnosis in there,
there's a drug in there,
there's a timeframe in there.
So I've got a bunch of
things I gotta figure out.
So the thing I'm gonna do first
is let's take a stop at the
medical coding specialist.
I gotta figure out what's
the coding for hypertension?
Is it one, is it many?
What's the coding for the
drug I'm looking for, right?
And then what's additional information
that might be of interest?
Are there lab codes that
might represent that drug?
It's one we we ran into
that was unexpected.
So once we've stopped
at the medical coding agent, that's great.
Now we gotta figure out
where this is in the dataset.
So we stop at the data navigator agent
and each one of these
stops is going through
this iterative loop of
understanding the task
that's given to it and
providing a high quality output
for the rest of the system to use.
So then we stop, of course,
at the SQL expert agent,
which we just talked about.
And then, finally, we land
on the visualization creator
because the supervisor
decided that this would be
a great use case to generate
some visualizations for.
So not only do we get
a high quality output
that's iteratively followed
almost what feels like
a very human logic kind of a process.
Then we've also been able to give
some high quality visualizations
based on the context of the
question that was asked.
And so as we built this system,
we learned some pretty valuable lessons.
The first one was, a great
thing about multi-agent systems
is multi-agents can be
evaluated individually.
And so it's really important
as you start to think
through the problem set
that you're addressing
and you start to build individual agents
that do these critically encapsulated,
almost atomic kind of skills things,
that you make sure that you
validate them individually.
Do they do the thing that you
think that they're supposed
to do given the problem
set that you've defined
when you thought about
the original problem set?
You gotta deep dive on
guardrails is the second one.
So one of the things that
we found very quickly
was that the complexity and the nuance
in language of the questions
that people would ask
in this space is really, really important
to get exactly right
because the criticality
of answering say a safety-related question
or not is paramount.
And so being able to
understand some of the nuances
and deep diving with the
subject matter experts
on what exactly are some of the nuances
that they do or do not want to allow
from an inputs and outputs perspective,
what's in the underlying data
or their say de-identification
kinds of concerns
or data privacy issues,
deep dive on guardrails is
really, really important.
Sorry.
And so the next one then is
perform system level validation.
So just because you've
validated the individual agents
doesn't mean that when
you put them all together
that the system is gonna
do what you expect.
So make sure that you
come up with a good set,
a good test set of questions
that you can run through
on a regular basis
as not only you move towards production,
but then also as you
change language models.
Sonnet 4.5 was just
released, I don't know,
a month ago or so, maybe not even.
And the pace of model change
is gonna continue to increase.
And so as new models come up,
it's very important to
be able to switch quickly
to new models, which means validation,
which means testing,
which means automation
and these are all really key things
to build into your original system.
Including human in the loop
is also very important.
Improving the quality of the outputs
based on the quality of the inputs.
I think Anne mentioned this early on.
This is almost a garbage
in, garbage out situation.
So including a human in
the loop in this case,
in a very passive way to provide
approval of golden queries
and human feedback on the quality
of that ground truth
reference for the agents
is really, really important.
And then, finally,
develop and track metrics.
Human feedback from experience,
quality of outputs, even just
latency of query execution.
These are all things as you
start to instrument your system
with observability capabilities,
like say as in AgentCore,
you really have the
opportunity to continually
and iteratively improve the
solution that you're building
by developing those and
tracking those metrics early on.
And so, finally, from
an overall standpoint,
as you think about building agents,
the key aspect here is
taking that raw data
into actionable insights.
And as you see, that's
a multi-step process.
A person can't do this in an instant
and neither can an agent system,
but the key is to build
yourself that research team
to be able to accomplish the
task that you're going for.
The second one is really key,
and Greg touched on this,
is this context aspect.
So it's about architecting
a set of tools, you know,
an overall kind of system architecture,
which results in the ability
to capture the right tools
that are gonna curate
that context to each agent
in the right place at the right time.
And actually one thing I'll mention
on that past one is model choice.
A lot of attention is paid
to model choice these days
and it's very, very important.
But increasingly so as the
models continue to evolve,
context becomes a critical
aspect of high quality,
high performance agent execution.
So the next one, of course,
is testing and observability.
And a lot of this has to do with rigor
around application or
solution development.
And then also picking the right framework
like a strands agent running on AgentCore
to be able to quickly and
easily instrument your system
with the observability
capabilities that you need
to move from dev all
the way to production.
And then, you know, building
an extensive ecosystem,
one of the great things
about multi-agent systems
is you can extend them
and add more capabilities.
As your problem set evolves,
you can build reusable
agents for different things
and you can imagine that
the medical coding agent
can be used for a lot of things.
It's not just exclusive to this use case.
And so being able to build individual,
capable agents and then
continuing to add more
and more agents, you know,
agent to agent communication now
as a protocol is becoming very popular
for this exact reason.
And so that's a really important
thing to be thinking about
is building that ecosystem of agents
so that they can plug
together is critical.
Safer and auditable workflows.
So, you know, one of the things
that like in this use case
embedding compliance into
the reasoning process,
being able to manage things like citations
as a part of the output is
a really important thing
to build trust in
consumers as they interact
with an AI system because they don't see
all of the reasoning.
So they need to know how the
agent arrived at the output.
And then, finally, that human
plus agent collaboration
is really, really important.
Greg touched on it with
regard to that, you know,
kind of interaction process
of question and answer,
question and answer dialogue.
But it's also really important,
as I mentioned earlier,
for a human to be involved
in a less direct capacity
to provide that ground truth.
That subject matter expertise is critical
for both this and probably
many of the use cases
that you might be thinking about today.
And then, finally, of course,
we always want you to build on AWS.
The agent services continue
to evolve on the AWS platform
to an incredible set of
capabilities that enable you
to move forward with your
development to production process.
And with that in mind,
we will be at Sushisamba
tomorrow, 12:45 to 2:45.
So please come and see us.
We'll be doing a demo
of this actual solution
on a real-world dataset.
So please come join us and hopefully
we'll see you at Sushisamba tomorrow.
With that in mind, the
Life Sciences team at AWS
has also built an incredible
set of accelerators
in addition to the RWD agent.
This is things like
competitive intelligence,
what we call Clinical
Supply Chain Control Tower.
And the intent of these solutions
is to say how do you get from idea
to production in the fastest way?
You can take that native build process,
which I know as builders we like to do,
but then also you can
use that AWS OS toolkit
for Life Sciences as a next step.
And then, finally, of course,
with the accelerators that we're
building and iterating over
with customers like yourselves,
we're able to get there even faster
by doing say 40 or 50 or
60% of the work already.
So we can hand you something
and partner with you
to move forward to production.
So really excited to
hopefully see a lot of you
at Sushisamba tomorrow to
talk about real-world data,
as well as the other
accelerators that we have.
If you're interested in more information,
grab the QR code here,
get some more information
on the agentic accelerators.
Of course, also in the
the massive expo hall,
please come and see us at
the Industries Pavilion,
the Life Sciences team from AWS.
We'll be there today and
and for the rest of the week
and we'll be excited to see
any one of you as come out.
And, you know, please, again,
thank you for your time today.
Hopefully you learned
something from this session.
Please provide feedback
on the session content
with the survey and hope everybody
has a great rest of their day.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)